dozens are killed in a container depot
explosion in bangladesh it's the latest
incident to trigger debate on the
country's poor industrial safety
standards so is enough being done to
protect workers this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i am
hashem
unfortunately industrial accidents are
too common in bangladesh in the latest
incident dozens of people were killed in
a fire and explosion
at a container port near the city of
chatogram
hundreds were seriously wounded doctors
say most people died in the explosion or
from inhaling toxic fumes
firefighters believe a container of
chemicals may have caused the blaze
special branch of the military has been
called in to help with this salvage
operation tenuish choudary has more from
the capital decca
rescue and salvage operation is still
continuing bangladesh firefighters have
been held by special unit of the army it
is still not clearly out of danger many
of the containers still has fumes and
small fires
they are worried that many of the
containers could have flammable
chemicals so this is a danger zone
hospitals are overwhelmed many of the
injured have been brought to the capital
city dhaka now the government has
announced a compensation package for the
injured victims and those who died for
their families the prime minister and
the president send their condolence to
the families
bangladesh as we know has a history of
industrial accidents since 2013 rana
plaza
industrial accident much have been
improved in this country especially in
the textile and government sector but
much needs to be improved in other
sector it's a fast growing economy with
many industries coming up the
firefighting equipments are not up to
the time it has to deal with high-rise
building chemical industries and many
other sophisticated industries that
growing around different parts of the
country now we know there's a limited
resource there is a lack of firefighting
equipment in many places there is lack
of enforcement experts have warned that
in lieu of time bangladesh firefighting
unit needs to be trained better and
better acute the most important part
they must be able to enforce these laws
in these factories and other places
those are clearly in danger of accidents
and fire
sandvik chaudhary for inside story
let's take a quick look at major
industrial accidents in bangladesh
during the last decade
in 2012 117 workers died with locked
exit doors trapped them in a garment
factory on fire in the capital dhaka
five months later the country suffered
its worst industrial disaster when the
rana plaza clothing factory collapsed
more than a thousand a hundred people
were killed
in 2019 a blaze swept through an area
crammed with apartments shops and
warehouses in the oldest part of dhaka
killing at least
70 people
and 52 people died last june when a fire
destroyed a food and drink factory many
were trapped inside by a door that was
illegally locked
bangladesh recently held its first
industrial safety forum with the
international labor organization
they discussed developing a national
industrial safety framework with a focus
on building safety and better protection
for workers government ministers say
committees have been set up to review
labor laws civil society groups say
smaller factories that make up the bulk
of the industrial sector often failed to
carry out routine safety checks
let's bring in our guests in dhaka
honda roland
research director of the center for
policy dialogue think tank together with
the international labour organization
they organized the first industrial
safety forum last month in brussels
ben
van pepper strata senior legal advisor
at the european center for
constitutional and human rights
and the london stephen cotton general
secretary of the international transport
workers federation it has 15 affiliated
unions in bangladesh welcome to the
program
honda i mean from past incidents could
this be another act of negligence and
poor safety procedures
i think you're right that this is one of
a reflection of lack of governance
in case of the industrial safety point
of view bangladesh has over the last one
decade has made improvement industrial
safety in the regiment government sector
which is the major export products but
similar kinds of uh industrial safety
haven't yet actually insured for
non-ready-made garment uh products uh
and chemical industries and and because
of that these kinds of incidents
happened in bangladesh so we need to
actually now think of improvement of the
industrial safety not only on the one
sector but across the board for all
important safety concern related sectors
and industries
ben i mean on paper the government would
tell you've made some progress when you
look at this particular incident 4 000
containers stored in a depot
and then some of those
containers have
chemical substances that
helped spread the fire uh the the fire
fighters were struggling to contain
the fire uh you don't get a sense
whatsoever that they have really learned
a great deal from past incidents
yeah i would fully concur with that
on paper bangladesh always looks stellar
the fire and building safety regulations
in the country on paper are up to the
mark they align with international
standards on fire and building safety
but the problem is that the regulations
remain a paper tiger because the problem
is really in the enforcement it's about
the inspectorate
how many people are in the expec
inspectorate so the inspectorate also
has the mandate to compel specific
actions for example closing something or
temporary uh shutting some uh some high
risk areas down does it have actually
enough independence feasibility
decides to inspect the real problem in
bangladesh has been and still
unfortunately remains enforcement
stefan
many now are
blaming
small
factories
in dhaka for the incidents that have
been taking place for the last few years
you have 15 unions which are affiliated
uh
with you
what is the biggest concern what is the
biggest problem as far as their presence
in bangladesh is concerned
thanks sesame i think just echoing the
the other commentators that the big
challenge is making sure that what's
written up both in the legislation and
the guidelines about occupational health
and safety are enforceable and delivered
so for us that the big concern here
seems to be
that containers with unidentified
contents
so the firefighters don't know how to
respond and there's obviously a question
in the leading
part of the article about is the
standard good enough for for really
for chemicals are highly flammable and
very dangerous so the question is for us
is
enforcement transparency and how to
respond so for all of our unions which
are mostly in the transport sector
it's all about ensuring that the
international standards go into
bangladesh and reinforces
i mean the blast shook an entire
neighborhood
and is raising questions about the same
issue that people were
concerned about for many years which is
the presence of chemical plants located
in proximity with
with towns and nothing has been done
about this
yes you are right that over the years uh
this is these kinds of incidences
happened and earlier also the the same
kinds of incidents we observed
in the vicinity of the of the locality
where lots of people actually uh stay
put and but no no major changes happen
in terms of relocation of these kinds of
uh uh
uh of
of factories uh to a safer
places as well as
there are a lot of
proper culture developed to
improve the safety related compliances
in the factories what is the unfortunate
part here is that often an incidences
happen and after that uh our government
and other agencies uh look for uh who is
actually and uh responsible for that and
try to find out and and try to blame
each other but the problem here is that
no such safety culture has yet to
develop in case of the industrial safety
point of view here in bangladesh so it
is it is important to
create that kind of industrial safety
culture at the factory level so where it
is not actually look into the incidences
after uh after a factory has established
and its operation started but before
that when a and and when a
factory is actually built in from there
that on the safety related issues need
to be checked in properly registration
and licenses to be actually monitored
properly so that any kinds of incidences
uh won't be actually be reduced and that
kinds of things haven't yet actually
done so need to have a safety culture
from the very first um
since the establishment of the factory
and then its operation and finally uh
the uh
in the in the course of time so
this that kinds of culture and practice
need to be improved we will we will go
now into some details about the very
industry itself the regulations the law
the deals that have been signed in the
past and why we still have those
problems ben
the garment industry is the backbone of
the
uh bangladeshi economy accounts for
something like 80 percent of the export
revenues employs more than four million
people you get
you might think since this is the pride
of the nation the government would be
looking after it this is not the case
whatsoever
so that's that's totally that's
certainly right uh
garments are important for the export i
wouldn't say it's the backbone of the en
of the economy because there's also some
domestic sectors that are really
important but it is really the flagship
industrial sector and it is also the
flagship industrial sector in the sense
that
it's where as we saw earlier in the show
where a lot of these industrial
accidents have happened and where there
also were plenty of opportunities to
learn from and and and improve the labor
inspectorates as well as the fire and
building safety inspectors so
it is an important industry of the
country um it's an important industry
with lots of international attention but
it's also an industry that is that is
fraught with all kinds of problems where
we do see that fire building safety
issues are prevalent but also
labor rights are thwarted
significantly uh there is a problem of
limited freedom of association so
workers can't join our former union of
their own choosing the wages are low uh
now we just had kovitz where uh we saw
all kinds of workers uh working in even
poor occupational health and safety
situations uh sometimes being dismissed
without a safety net um
present
so there's all it's it's a sector
unfortunately that is rampant with
problems but
also a sector which is prevalent of
solutions know to be on how to build uh
an inspectorate that is capable of
actually inspecting uh the firearm
building say uh safety of specific
facilities on the one hand and secondly
where also compensation has already been
um provided according to international
standards know to be to the test ring
fire and the
uh the rana plaza disaster so there's
also so much that can already be taken
and mainstreamed throughout the economy
from that specific sector stefan
speaking about those solutions that ben
was talking about so you have this
industry where you have key players the
global fashion retailers the trade
unions you have 15 unions affiliated
with
with you and then you have the factory
owners and still we're having these same
problems do you think that this could be
the moment to talk about an independent
inspection mechanism that would be
overseeing all the different aspects of
the of the process to prevent such
incidents in the future
thanks essay that's a great question i
think for us there's there's first i
think we need an
independent investigation and i would
encourage
international observers because we need
to know exactly
what happened here the rhona plaza
situation gave us an opportunity to
connect the
lead firms the multinationals those with
a big reputation
directly as we would say to the supply
chain or to due diligence
and we think right now this is more
important than ever and ben mentioned it
uh covid highlighted
workplace occupational health and safety
and covid highlighted the weaknesses in
our global supply chains whether it be
from the manufacturing from the global
south to the to the global north now we
really have to look at how we're
accountable and i would encourage not
just the bangladeshi authorities but
also the clients of the factories the
occupational health and safety
authorities and again
it's not just a bangladeshi challenge to
have good quality labour inspectors who
enforce regulations so for us we see it
in the sense of due diligence so it
could be the multinational that
contracts the bangladeshi company what
we read to understand particularly in
this incident
is what exactly happened and what do we
need to put in place but the the battle
goes on and i think there's a big
question
certainly for your viewers and consumers
as a whole
we we all want to have
the best possible materials but we've
also got to understand that comes at a
price and bangladesh needs more
investment and we need to be able to
hold the clients
of the individual companies just one
point on the workers rights and freedom
of association
bangladesh has a checkered record in
this space
and it's difficult to raise
effective unions in very small factories
so we continue to work with parties our
unions
to have a strong relationship with
government have a tripartite model was
enforced by the ilo but we do need the
global employers to recognize they have
a responsibility to every worker in
their supply chain
i mean since the tragedy of 2013 there
have been
deals to try to regulate the whole
sector the 2021
international accord for health and
safety in the textile and garment
industry were was was widely seen as a
uh as a turning point because first of
all it's a legally binding uh
pact where all the parties will be held
accountable in case of a disaster
but in this particular case is it the
the atmosphere of impunity which has
been prevailing in your country
that has contributed to this
tragedy
i think uh
the ready-made government sector what we
have observed over the decade uh is a
some sort of shared responsibility both
from the brands buyers point of view as
well as from the suppliers in as well as
from the local government as well as
international um
sourcing countries and there therefore a
good uh
improvement happened in in terms of
improvement of the workplace safety in
the regiment government sector what is
unfortunate part here is that not all
the supply chains are so much strong
particularly
with regard to the global supply chain
and
we are very few of such
industries which have a strong global
supply chains other than the regiment
government sector and that has a major
problem here uh here is that that we
could actually create much more pressure
from the supplier buyers end to improve
the the workplace safety and security
unfortunately we observed that if the
brand's buyers and the international
buyers has taken a
major initiative from the global
compliance point of view it is rather
easier for improvement of the workplace
safety here and
for that point of view the
non-ready-made government sector has
limited participation of the
international uh branch buyers so that
is the challenge of the how we could
actually
improve it through the local level
initiatives that there are some
initiatives which are currently ongoing
bangladesh investment development
authority has taken an initiative by
inspecting 5000 factories but this is at
a very very uh
uh elementary level uh which has need to
have a major significant improvement in
terms of
inspecting and thereby creating a safety
framework unless and until a safety
framework could be established and all
the responsible agencies could be
brought in there
and to respond make responsible uh it is
rather difficult uh from the uh to
ensure the safety um
at this stage so i think a local level
initiative
for the non-ready-made government sector
is very very important for which this
industry safety forum under the ilo uh
that has now tried to establish an
industrial safety framework in the
country ben again i have here an issue
with the w w
with the
with the agreements with the intention
of the government but like with this
particular deal the last deal they said
that there is an entity called the
garment sustainability council that gsc
which
which is mandated to oversee the
implementation of the deal i ensure
that the workers in the garment industry
operate in a very safe environment
no warning whatsoever i mean you ask
anyone who is dealing with this sector
and he will tell you you know what it's
just a matter of time before another
incident will hit again and again
now that that analysis is certainly
correct because the the reason that that
once rana plaza happened people had to
resort to an international court was
notably a failure of the national
institutions to prevent this because
even before rana plaza or even before
tazreen there's also a decade of track
record of uh industrial accidents so
even at that moment in time and that's
unfortunately now almost 10 years ago
um
that was a disaster in the making and
people were already seeing it coming it
was just not clear when and in what
extent
so in that sense it's it's it's it's
very um painful to see how little has
been learned
whereas all the elements are are on the
table so
indeed maybe the reason that the accord
the international agreement between
brands and international union was
formed was notably to find a form of
accountability and transparency at the
international level knowing that the
collusion between
industry interests and the government
was was too intense in bangladesh to
allow for an independent inspectorate
here depending on the sector we we need
to
maybe tailor that a bit but the same
ingredients of independence to the
inspectorate accountability transparency
capacity
are on the table secondly everything
related to unions because mr cotton has
also focused on that unions in
bangladesh don't have a lot of space
the internet the labor laws
fall short to international minimum
standards and already again for a few
decades and the ilo has repeatedly
pointed its attention on that and
there's also repeatedly been roadmaps on
how to amend the labor law how to
improve the labor inspectorate etc how
to establish occupational health and
safety committees and so it's really
about reducing those points and then the
third pillar the third pillar is after
rana plaza and tazri we did manage to
come up with an international
compensation scheme which was aligned
with ilo convention one to one so there
is a approved model which is
up to the mark the question there was to
generalize that into a national
employment injury insurance scheme that
would have immediately now kick-started
compensation okay the victims and that's
still not on the table so that's also a
plan that is ready and ready to roll out
stephen when you look this is this is an
economy that is recovering from the
kovid 19 pandemic a few two years ago to
i mean 2.8 billion dollars worth of
orders were either cancelled or paused
now there is massive pressure on the
workers to boost production and people
are saying that wages safety conditions
now are going to be relegated to the
sidelines with all these concerns now
about safety procedures
so so for us the the principles laid out
by our ben or colleague from the ilo are
remain very very strong
i think
it's critical
and we learned throughout the kovid
period that you have to build very
strong collaborations and i think it's
our invitation to the bangladeshi
government but also the leading brands
that are those contractors
i think it's utterly critical in the
european union we've seen new laws
coming in france and laws in the process
in germany about due diligence and what
does that mean it means
that the contractor or the economic
employer the multinational lead firm has
responsibility all the way through the
supply chain
now we understand the economic pressure
uh on the on the bangladeshi government
to bring foreign currency but of course
it doesn't work unless you have the
pillar of a strong
independent
in labor inspectorate it doesn't work
unless you have strong trade unions to
represent the workers in the workplace
and with an influence in the legislation
so for us it's a critical time to
reflect this incident is one of many
something isn't working as it should do
and we need to re-energize the
significant stakeholders and let's be
very clear it's the economic power of
the multinational firms that needs to be
brought to play
to hold each and every part of the
supply chain so the manufacturing uh the
transportation the depot that we're in
question here into an accountability in
a very clear standard and of course all
of us in the labor movement are very
keen thank you to to be part of that
process thank you
vampire strata and stephen cotton i
really appreciate you inside thank you
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website al jazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
incisor you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj insight story from mihashim
and the entire team here in doha bye for
now
you